the US Navy has released the names of
the seven sailors who died when the USS
Fitzgerald collided with a cargo ship
off the coast of Japan the youngest
victim was just 19 years old the oldest
37 they come from Virginia California
Connecticut Texas Maryland and Ohio Ben
Tracy has details of what we know about
the cargo ships movements before the
collision and the heroic efforts to save
the destroyer he's in Beijing
Ben good morning good morning there are
now four investigations into this
incident three by US authorities and one
by the Japanese but so far none of them
can say how this massive cargo ship
seemingly without warning got close
enough to a u.s. Navy destroyer to
collide with it
the impact crushed the starboard side of
the USS Fitzgerald the ship was listing
as it sailed into its home port in
Yokosuka Japan Saturday the commander of
the u.s. seventh Fleet said the actions
of the roughly 300 sailors on board kept
this ship from sinking this was not a
small collision it was right near the
pilots house and there is a big puncture
the other ship a Filipino vessel called
the ACX crystal sustained minor damage
to its bow the cargo ship which is about
four times heavier nearly t-boned the
Navy destroyer around 2:20 a.m. Saturday
when much of the crew was asleep and the
bridge likely manned by less than a
dozen people it happened more than 50
nautical miles south of Tokyo which was
supposed to be the crystals destination
but according to marine traffic calm the
cargo ship made a u-turn shortly before
the crash and was headed in the opposite
direction both ships had that
responsibility to try to avoid each
other
CBS radio military analyst Mike Lyons
has a language barrier
equipment failure or human error could
all be factors whoever was on the bridge
was likely inexperienced did not
recognize the danger that was going but
also could have been accelerating to
possibly try to avoid the container ship
as well commander Brice Benson the
Fitzgeralds captain had to be airlifted
off the ship during the collision he was
in his cabin which was destroyed the
sleeping quarters for
sixteen sailors flooded seven died
including Gunner's Mate second class no
way Hernandez he just loved the military
that's all he wanted to do was be a
soldier 19 year old seaman Dakota Rigsby
was a volunteer firefighter before he
joined the Navy to know him is to love
him he is a he was a good strong hearted
person skyler clique who survived told
his father the crew used a bucket
brigade to keep the ship afloat
the pumps weren't enough so they had a
bucket line to keep the ship from
totally sinking this like bucket at a
time the Japanese Coast Guard has now
questioned the 20 member crew of that
cargo ship none of them were actually
injured the owner of the company says
that their thoughts are with the
families of the lost American sailors
meanwhile the Prime Minister of Japan
has sent his condolences to presidential
chef Ben Tracy and Beijing thank you